goodness so we we did uh
let's get it we'll go slow okay so I'm
gonna come around
with my technique here's a post on that
and you see ah no no no that's not gonna
work
well
close take one more time and then you're
gonna make it
come on
oh
around when you feel that post you take
one more tank on around you're on the
wrist
ankle
dog
okay so you see his arm
I'm gonna Tank on
slide
we get you wouldn't move there and I'll
be here
and now when he comes around for his
attack that's when he runs and it
attacking
so I'm not
gonna
find a return
that I'm going to take one ten con and
then this hand is already in place
for the nickel
[Music]
okay okay so I'll go slow so you can see
then the hand change okay so you're
going to come around
boom he's going to post
uh
he can't put his hand down because I
have the technique you see in this
centrifugal energy
so when you posts don't move him anymore
keep this arm
slide down here there's there's your
Rocio this is kind of Slide the Roku
you come around here
elbow hand
goes
to the to the wrist
here
everything slides down
to the wrist there it is okay oh if he
doesn't move at me you'll have rokio but
in the keyhole he's gonna move around
with me so I give up the rokio and take
the Nico
I do it again
we're here all right when I feel the
post don't move them anymore
move you one more ten come on
there's your rokio
is he's coming around I give up the
rokio
[Music]
says
thank you
[Music]
so don't don't uh let's go
I'm still holding him
still holding him
still trapped
so uh
if I am
he's down
uh Mountain
okay so I'm trying for my figure four
here you see and uh I can't get his
shoulder this is too freaking strong
he's
um so I'm gonna try for the elbow you
see but he's all he's all effing with me
too strong he's moving around I can't
get he's supporting it with his other
hand he's seeing all kinds of like
that so I fake fake fake and then I'm
gonna go for his wrist do you see that
but during the transition
there's no letting go
you get that so I can't go
uh shoulder
no shoulders not working elbow no wrist
because he's gonna get out
so as you play the shoulder elbow wrist
dilemma you can't let go
you got it you can't let go because the
arm will not be there
so as I come up pull around we go boom
you see I'm not letting go okay
and I don't want to do anything
like
this stuff like you
so if you pay attention
if to have his elbow on top which is
wrist
is going to be in the right place
this I'm not going to turn his wrist
if I just stay there if I just move his
arm over here
you see I didn't turn his arm at all
there is his wrist in the right place
you see
do you guys get that
so
that way
I can keep the arm
keep the arm keep the arm keep the arm
with no
no anything like that okay the arms in
the same place
and the way you get the arm the Nico is
you move you
and his arm
there
you see
you you by doing that 10 count so look
for how I'm doing that okay one
cool resist and I move there there's the
sound it's in the right place
all I do is put it up and wait
boom
very good right tank on around there it
is in the right place I didn't have to
turn the sand at all
it's in the right place because if you
have the push pull on the arm that we've
talked about so he cannot post that ham
his wrist is at this island
so that's why if I move it over here
it's going to be in the field without
turning
[Music]
that tencon
helps me get
to the length of the arm
[Music]
here
if I go out to this side
I have to kind of Judge it all the time
but the tech he's counting the technique
and by doing the tank on I stay in the
back of him you see
plus it's the perfect length in measures
[Music]